FACE-OFF.
AND THE,
COVERED AGAIN BY THE RANGERS AND
POKED AROUND ON THE WALL.
ENDS UP COMING TO CENTER ICE.RO
DOWN BY BUFFALO AGAIN FOR
DAHLIN.
HE SWEEPS AW
CENTER ICE WITH A PASS AHEAD.
OVER THE LINE.
PANARIN GETS A SHOT. TO THE
POINT.
BACK IN ALONG THE WALL AGAIN.
TAKEN BY COZENS.
HOOKEDEDMILLER, THERE IS THE
SHOT.
TH
THAT ONE WENT ALL WAYS EXCEPT
THE RIGHT IS TAKEN BY BUFFALO.
IN BEHIND
HINOSTROZA, ON TO THOMPSON.
THOMPSON COMING A A
KILLING THIS ONE OFF BUT LOOK AT
THESE PASSING PLAYS.
STROME MISSED.
ALL THE WAY AROUND THE BOARDS
BUT KEPT IN BY BUFFALO.
ON THE
NOW UP ON THE WING.
OLOFSSON, TAPPED AHEAD BUT
INTERCEPTED AND KEPT IN THERE.
A SHOT.
THAT GOES WIDE. IN.
STEERED OUT AND PICKED UP BY THE
RANGERS WHO WILL FLIP IT HIGH TO
CENTER.
IN OVER THEOUND TO THE OTHER SI.
COLIN MILLER.
HINOSTROZA, BACK TO THE POINT. .
GREAT RE OUT.
THOMPSON KEPT IT
HERE WE GO.N.
AND BUFFALO SWIPING IT BACK
AGAIN WITH EAKIN PASSS FAR SIDE.
CODY EAKIN WITH A
ON THE REBOUND, LAFRENIERE HE R.
RIGHT HERE, THEHE
HE DOES.
ALL THE WAY AROUND THE BOARDS,
BACK
FOX.
FOX PUTS IT ON THE OTHER S THE .
BUT BUFFALO  THE SAVE,
DAHLIN AS THE PLAY WAS GOING UP?
>> Rob: WELL, IT'S
SCORE!
BRETT MURRAY WAS TO COME FREE TO
BOARDS. IT?
I DON'T KNOW.
THOMPSON HAD A CHANCE.RIGHT UP .
GOALTENDER KNOCKS IT INTO THE  .
>> Referee: AFTER REVIEW, THE
PLAYEMAIN.
INTO THE CORNER.
CHIPPED OFF THE BOARDS.